[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we have a very special
video for you I told you that if we got
1000 likes on the 10 ways for kids
changed one-piece video that I do a part
too and as I'm writing this script we've
reached over 150,000 views with over
3,500 likes that's insane and it means
that this video is definitely overdue I
do want to make it clear though that
this video should be viewed as a
companion piece to the original video so
if you haven't checked that one out I'll
put a link in the description that one
goes into much more detail and this one
we'll be building off of it
now if you haven't already do me a favor
and hit that subscribe by the
notification bell so you know the
instant we upload a new one-piece video
let's say that if we can get another
1000 likes on this video we'll do
another for kids special so just let me
know which other four kids dubbed anime
you would like to see broken down keep
in mind this video is not meant to be
taken as an unrelenting assault on four
kids there's plenty of those already
that's not what I'm trying to do here
even though it feels that way at times I
just want to point out some differences
that I thought were worthy of your
attention now whether you've seen the
four kids dub or not sit back relax and
get ready for some of the most
hilariously bizarre changes you've ever
seen
number one the voices when people think
of the four kids dub for one piece one
of the main things that sticks out is
the horrible voice acting now to be fair
it's not the voice actors for to blame
because they were just following
directions nevertheless people are
simultaneously angered and amused by the
four kids voices luffy's voice was
criticized for being extremely goofy and
high-pitched all the time but the two
main voices that stand out are Sanji's
and Nico Robbins
Sanji has a nasally voice on top of a
thick Brooklyn accent take a listen what
my life I agree with Sherwood many fans
hate Sanjay's voice and think it's all
wrong for the character but I also have
a friend who actually likes it a lot so
it definitely wasn't a deal breaker for
everyone let me know what you think
about Sanjay's nasally voiced in the
description below do you love it or do
you hate it
next we have Nico Robin's voice this one
is amusing because she has a Texas
accent solely due to the fact that she
wears a cowboy hat during the alabasta
arc my body parts bloom like flowers I'm
a bouquet let me know if there are any
other voices that really stood out to
you number two tattoos we discussed how
drinking alcohol and smoking
we're edited out of the four kids dub in
the previous video and the same goes for
tattoos for instance mr. Juan's tattoos
are gone and so are aces I suppose for
kids thought that kids might rush to get
tattoos if they saw them in the show and
not wanting that they erased them all
together I guess they didn't wanna ace
tattoo up their sleeve
[Laughter]
number three changing names we briefly
touched upon this in the first video
hashtag don't give it up solo probably
the most infamous name change was that
of Zorro - Zolo but there were plenty of
other name changes for example aces name
was changed to trace and Edward Newgate
was changed to ward new gates some name
changes were ridiculous but at least we
understood why four kids change them
captain smoker was changed to captain
chaser you know because we don't want
kids secretly finding out that this cool
dude is a chain-smoker
whiskey Peak was changed to misty peak
because not even a hint of alcohol can
remain in the dub
however aces and Edwards name changes
seem completely unnecessary and
unexplainable also it is noteworthy to
mention that Sanji's attacks which were
originally named after French cooking
terms were changed to food based puns
which leads us excellently to our next
change number four pun ception
the ceaseless onslaught of
pons is president every episode of the
four kids dug one critic said that the
puns were so lame that even the most art
and Garfield fans would think they were
infantile now I love puns and you'll see
plenty of puns in my videos but I've
never seen anyone pack so many bad puns
in a 30-minute show trust me when I say
they never miss an opportunity for a pun
and when there was no need or
opportunity for one you can bet they
awkwardly crammed one or two in anyways
here is a small taste tip bird lips next
time whenever mr. zero needs a hand I
answered the call to arms so you're well
armed number five Luffy versus crocodile
what is this the fight between crocodile
and Luffy was definitely an intense one
and for kids and everything within their
power to undermine that intensity I
mentioned in the last video how Luffy's
blood which allowed him to successfully
fight after crocodile was changed into
sweat in the for kid stuff however in
this video I want to show you guys this
tremendous bit of editing right here
like what is this atrocity they took one
of the most powerful frames in one piece
one of the scariest moments in a cartoon
and made it a WTF moment by the way let
me know what your number one WTF moment
in anime was in the comment section
below this should be good
number six no death for you 2.0 in the
first video we discussed the way four
kids change bell Amir's death scene into
a you're going to prison scene well
there's more where that came from
queena tragically died in the original
one piece
Zorro was devastated it contributed to
his characterization and affirmed his
ambitions to become the greatest
swordsman four kids seem to have made
Queen as fate even worse in the dub
instead of dying from the fall
she went into a never-ending coma after
being brutally assaulted good one for
kids number seven the little garden
vanishes /
drowning in plotholes as mentioned in
part one many canon parts AKA parts that
were in the manga were removed in the
four kids dub and this didn't just
include random tiny parts
it also included entire arcs in the
previous video we focused on the removal
of the reverse mountain arc and its
ramifications and now we're going to
turn our attention to the removal of the
little garden arc and the consequences
of that decision in the for kids dubbed
orion biragi were never introduced which
is a problem in and of itself because
they're awesome characters who have an
interesting and moving story to tell in
their own right on top of that
Musab was greatly inspired by these two
giant warriors the arc was significant
for his characterization and the
experience made him eventually want to
see el baths the Kingdom where the
Giants came from
not to mention this would have created
plot holes later on because o sob would
not have been able to convince a mole
and Kashi to drawing their cause at any
lobby
luckily for kids didn't get that far but
let this be a lesson to all dubbing
companies never skip over cannon
material ever PS it was also in the
little garden arc that mr3 was
introduced to straw hats and ami
contracted her illness since the arc was
removed these instances led to
inconsistencies later on as well for
example Nami was bitten by a Castilla in
little garden but they changed it to
grand line fever since in the for kids
world they never went to the prehistoric
island and yet later on forecasts
contradict themselves anyway by having
kuraha ask Nami if she had been on a
prehistoric island alas for kids can't
even be consistent with their
inconsistencies number 8 how dare you
point that slingshot at me we talked
about some weird instances of gun
censorship in the first video sometimes
four kids made guns look like water guns
and sometimes they simply colored the
guns green however in this instance four
kids changed the gun into a slingshot
during Cayenne Crowes confrontation
kiyah
originally pulls out a gun which you
know actually lends gravity to the
Scituate
and gives off the idea that kya could
potentially kill crow if she just pulled
the trigger however even if that
slingshot was in Aesop's hands it
wouldn't be a threat to crow and the
terrible editing definitely doesn't help
the situation the only other thing that
could have lessened the severity of the
moment even more would be if kya told
crow to eat ur shorts number 9 taking a
bath in alabasta it's no surprise that
for kids has a problem with any hint of
nudity even cleavage is a no-go there
were many instances where for kids
censored suggestive content or revealing
outfits they simply loved censoring
Robin for obvious reasons in this video
let's see how four kids decided to
change the sacred bath scene in alabasta
we first see the guys goofing around and
Sanji asks about the location of the
girls bath Ingram is mad but King Cobra
points them they're infuriating a Guren
we then see vivvy in a towel washing
Tommy's naked back you don't really see
much but Nami is naked and you can see
some cleavage accompanied by steam a
classic anime moment then they see all
the guys looking over the wall by the
way I love chopper hair looking sideways
awesome and then Nami removes the towel
we get the happiness punch and as we'd
expect in true anime fashion we get a
fountain of blood spraying from every
dudes nose and the animal dudes
- Vivian shocked and every guy is out of
commission after that deadly blow that
is the happiness punch now enter for
kids every dude is given a towel the
King talks about meditation and
reflecting on the meaning of life
instead of telling the others where Nami
and Vivi's bath is king cobra apparently
was gonna make a speech a [ __ ] RAM is
extremely upset uncharacteristically so
in fact we are gathered here
no speeches like wow this guy has some
strong feelings about speeches and then
we get into a 30 second argument about
speeches and how no one wants to hear a
speech jump to the girls Nami and vivvy
are in a hot tub have a virtually
meaningless conversation and they are
both given swimsuits and the main scenes
are gone altogether literally nothing
happens and scene number 10 accidently
inappropriate to the extreme we looked
at how despite trying to help the
situation many ways fork has made Queen
as fate worse than the dub right well
just wait until you hear this one as
mentioned previously suggestive content
was removed for the most part but
sometimes for kids actually added it in
themselves out of everything that Nico
Robin could have said she said that she
uses her Hana Hana no me devil fruit aka
her multiple hands for
rub out in essence she straight-up says
her specialty is rubbing people out one
search on urban dictionary will let you
know that that's an extremely
inappropriate thing to say for kids
especially when it's coming from a
central character like Nico Robin and
yes rub out can also mean to assassinate
someone but I think we all know and four
kids should definitely have known that
that's not the first thing anyone will
think of I don't think even oh that
could have been more inappropriate in
this situation if he tried and believe
me he definitely does try another
youtuber teching 101 has a hilarious
reaction to the scene which you can
check out on his second channel I'll put
a link in the description
he actually reacts to many four cos
episodes and if you feel like a
masochist and want to see even more from
Zolo and Robin the cowgirl be sure to
check out his channel and that's it for
this video thank you so much for
watching all the way to the end guys to
show your support and that you made it
this far type in hashtag nosebleed in
the comment section if you haven't
already make sure to watch part 1 which
is full of even more crazy changes that
you wouldn't believe if you liked this
video make sure to smash that like
button and subscribe for more insane
videos like this one let me know what
for kids anime you want us to
deconstruct next and after we hit 1000
likes on this video it may just be the
next one we discuss real talk I am so
thankful for you guys and for your
ongoing support you guys make all the
work that goes into these videos 110
percent worth it until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]